- We're sitting here
(beat boxing)
drinking pumpkin spice
lattes from dis, diff, ahh.
(beat boxing)
(hinge squeaks)
(upbeat music)
- Pumpkin Spice Latte is back.
- I never drink it, I'm more
of a black coffee kinda guy.
- It doesn't seem right.
Pumpkin and coffee?
- Have you ever had pumpkin pie?
- No.
(upbeat banjo music)
- Wait we have five?
- Oh my God.
- I thought we were
- What?
- trying one.
- Oh my God.
(upbeat jazz music)
- Ooh, it's in a mystery cup.
- Oh it smells sweet.
- Cheers.
- Mmm.
- I can't taste pumpkin.
- It's like chocolate and pumpkin.
- That's got McDonald's
written all over it.
(buzzer buzzes)
- I think it's a good balance between
pumpkin spice and everything else
- Mmhmm.
- and it's not like a
punch in your face of
flavor and artificial-ness.
(slide whooshes)
(upbeat jazz music)
- If we were scoring chai lattes,
I would say three out of five.
- I like chai and I like pumpkin spice.
I like sushi and I like
nachos, but I would never
have them together in one dish.
- You can't call something pumpkin if it's
not gonna taste like it.
- I think this is McDonald's.
(buzzer buzzes)
(slide whooshes)
(upbeat piano music)
- Enticing.
- Like an older pumpkin, it's
like a more mature pumpkin.
(woman laughs)
- Hmm, good, lovely.
We'll take the bottle.
- With whiskey by a fire, naked,
laying on a polar bear rug.
- This makes me want to adult.
- Is Coffee Bean number three?
(bell rings)
Oh my God.
Aussies know their
coffee mate.
- Coffee genius.
- Cheers to Coffee Bean, well done.
(slide whooshes)
(slow saxophone music)
- This one's curdling.
- I feel gunky.
Woah, no that's just probably cinnamon.
- Oh okay.
- This one's really orange.
- There's nothing pumpkin-y.
If it's not Starbucks,
everyone watching this video
can get a dollar from my bank account.
- This tastes more like
coffee than the others.
- It's really watery,
there's this like weird,
ashy aftertaste.
- Yeah.
- This is Starbucks.
(bell rings)
- Ugh.
(screams)
- Ah, no.
(slide whooshes)
(upbeat music)
- Do you know what this smells like?
Icing on a beautiful cinnamon cake.
- It's tangy.
- There's definitely more coffee
than there is
- Yeah.
- pumpkin spice.
- I can keep drinking it.
Not going out on a limb
and sayin' I'd get a venti,
but I'd definitely smash a grande.
- Dude, this is good.
- This one's not good, not bad.
I'm happy.
- Coffee, pump, pump,
sugar, pump, pump, coffee.
- Is it McDonald's?
(bell rings)
(upbeat music)
It's all I've heard Americans talk about
since landing in this fine country.
- I'll be at Coffee Bean.
- You can all leave me alone now
with my Starbucks and my pumpkin.
(upbeat music)
(logo whooshes)
(hinge squeaks)